in the introduction to ecology we
introduced the idea of a community which
is all about different populations that
are in the same habitat that share the
same area or that are in the same area
so populations and if we're thinking in
terms of water or in the air could be
the share share is similar volume even
populations sharing sharing a habitat
sharing a habitat and in particular in
this video we're going to focus on the
interactions between those populations
the interactions between the different
species the technical term for that is
interspecific interactions I like to
just say interactions between species
now the first one that is often thought
about is the notion of competition
competition and this is when different
populations different species are
competing for the same resources you can
imagine a forest where you have
different populations of plants that are
competing for sunlight that are
competing for water that are competing
for nutrients in the soil even in this
picture right over here this is a
picture of a community all of these
different populations of fish and other
things sea anemones and coral they are
sharing this same region and many of
them could be in competition with each
other they might be going after the same
food that we or they might be going
after the same shelter someplace and
oftentimes when people are talking about
these interspecies or interspecific
interactions you'll see something like
this a - slash - or a negative sign
slash a negative sign and that means
that this type of interaction when you
have two species or two populations that
are in competition with each other the
more that you have of one it's going to
have a negative effect on the other and
vice versa if I'm a plant and if I'm in
competition with another plant and that
one's taking my light and if there's
more of it taking my light that's going
to have a negative impact on me advice
versa if I'm in competition with you and
we eat the same thing the more of me
that there's around eating your food
that's going to have a negative impact
on you and vice versa so the next form
of interspecific in
action or interaction between species is
predation is predation this is when one
population likes to eat another
population and you might often associate
predation with pictures like this that
you see on on television shows on
documentaries you see a cheetah hunting
it looks like a cheetah hunting a a
gazelle or a deer of some kind
actually it says right here it's a young
Bush back and this is predation and but
this is not the only form of predation
this picture here of the goat eating
grass this is also predation it's not
quite as bloody and is violent but it is
still predation because you have one
species eating another put species in
this case you have this animal the goat
that is eating the grass and this type
of predation the specific type of
predation is called herbivore a
herbivore
but it is a type of predation so we
could say predation / herbivore let me
do a little slash here / herbivore II
which is a special case of predation and
you'll often see a + / - the more of
let's say this species that you have the
the species that is being eaten it's
going to benefit the predator but the
more of the predator that you have it's
going to have a negative effect on the
actual prey now the next the next types
of interactions are ones where you have
long term very fairly intimate
interactions they are the where you have
organisms that that often time live with
each other or even on each other and
this general term of organisms that have
these long term intimate interactions is
symbiosis symbiosis now in everyday
language when people talk about
symbiosis they're often talking about
organisms that really benefit each other
but technically symbiosis isn't just
about benefiting each other it could be
that they're even hurting each other in
some way or that maybe one benefits
while the other one really doesn't care
and so there are several types of
symbiosis the first that we could talk
about is parasitism para
Pera sit ISM and this looks a lot like
predation where the more the more the
the parasite benefits the more of the
host that there is but the host is
actually hurt by the parasite and
there's all sorts of examples of
parasitism we have right over here a
zoomed in picture of a louse so why is
this parasitism well if this lice of
this louse I should say so this is
parasitism parasitism and we would call
the this right the light the louse here
a parasite parasitism and this benefits
by living in your hair because that's
where it gets its food from it can lay
or living on your scalp it gets your
food by sucking your blood it can also
lay eggs in your hair in some ways you
could view it as almost shelter from
from the rest of the environment but
it's negative for you it will make you
itchy it is taking your blood it is
uncomfortable and so parasitism once
again it's good for the parasite just
like predation is good for the predator
but not so good for the host in the case
of parasitism now you have another
situation where it is benefiting both
sides and that is called mutualism
mutualism let me do that in a different
color so mutualism this is where both
sides benefit and oftentimes when people
talk about symbiosis they're really
talking about mutualism which is a
specific type of symbiosis where both
species were both animals organisms
benefit they don't have to just be
animals this is an example of mutualism
right here let me do that in a color you
can see so this is mutualism where you
have where you have a clownfish living
within a sea anemone the sea anemone is
providing the clownfish shelter while
the clownfish is keeping away other fish
that might eat that sea anemone so they
are both benefiting from that
interaction and so that is mutualism now
you have another category
we're one where one species is
benefiting and the other one is maybe a
little bit more and different so one
species is benefiting and then the other
one well maybe it is a little bit
indifferent and we call that
commensalism amensalism and once again
there's many examples of commensalism
this right here is a picture of bacteria
living on your skin and you do have
bacteria living on your skin right now
except it's actually well oftentimes
it's a good thing sometimes it's
mutualism that it's providing protection
from harmful bacteria but sometimes it
the bacteria is surely benefiting it's
its living off of nutrients on your skin
the skin is its habitat but often times
it doesn't really have an impact on you
now commensalism let me write this soo
down commensalism often times the more
that we study it and the more that we
understand it we realize that actually
maybe maybe the host actually is
benefiting in which it is mutualism or
maybe the host actually is getting hurt
in which case it is parasitism so
oftentimes commensalism isn't completely
neutral for the host it could go either
way
and so these are all the different types
of interactions so I encourage you look
around you look at the world around you
and don't just limit yourself to animals
think about bacteria think about plants
and think about within a habitat what
are all of the different interspecies
interactions and how you might want to
classify them